[Music]
welcome to this week's winners on a
Wednesday I'm here with my good friend
in Jeremy Greg and Jeremy has gone
through the crash course he's done a lot
of property training with myself and the
team he quit his job as a teacher two
years ago from a successful network
marketing business now is in property he
just made seventy thousand pound from
his last deal so Jeremy welcome to the
show how you doing yeah very well thanks
a lot you're very welcome thanks for
coming so turns up about your background
and where you kind of came from one
based in Cornwall I've talked for a very
very long time and I love the job and I
think you're probably aware the longer
you spend in a job more success we get
the further away you actually get from
your roots so I was a teacher for 18 20
years I left to develop property back in
2004 and got caught in the recession in
2008 when I believe you bought your
first place yeah and you know I know you
shouldn't regret things but looking back
if I had went through that again I would
beg borrow steal money to try and
reinvest at that point so hold on you
left you left job as a teacher to be a
property developer in 2004 yeah did you
buy many properties then we bought
refurbishment properties so you sold
them yeah and you were getting selling
them well we kept three yeah which have
let our and actually help my cash flow
but they were single debts some flats
that we kept and to be honest with the
obviou
we we got greedy the last job was rather
than amazing at that we converted into
two flats we ended up with a nice place
looking out to sea and we bought the
place with an idea to flip it in two or
three months and just before the day
before exchange the credit crunch hit
all the news hit and we ended up losing
enough money for me to make a decision
to go back to teach him so that must
have been absolutely demoralizing
leaving your job as a teacher to be a
property developer and then having to go
back to your job how did that feel yeah
it was a tough one it was a really tough
one and you know
as a teacher do not I love working with
kids and it wasn't an issue of going
back to teaching but yeah mr. G dreams
crushed yeah and it was a it was
definitely a mindset thing and for me
you know I went back and I was still
searching for something else we kept
some property I've got three children
which I need to support which was the
decision that I made at that time you go
back and support them for the regular
income and everything that we talked
about and I was really searching for
something at that stage to learn about
passive income and I knew a rental
property out I think I've heard you and
your brother talk about leaving money in
deals and at that stage because we were
short of money and paying back money to
different people through the development
you know I wasn't leaving enough in
property yeah
actually I wasn't treating as a business
if I'm honest with you and and I'd been
in a [ __ ] situation as a teacher where
with my personal finances yeah I didn't
have to be so so careful with that and
one of the biggest things I think I
picked up from your crash course special
I think one of the biggest things from
the crash course was about property as a
business and each property that you have
should be run as a business yeah
actually
your personal finances should be run as
a business and the pots of money has
been a massive change for me so several
years on from that Jen after my decision
to leave teaching for the second time
and lucky enough there was network
marketing there that's what introduced
me to personal developments and you know
the company that I work with was a
personal development company that
happened to introduce people to
utilities yeah many from utilities and
Oh be honest with you you know for a
long time I didn't read didn't read a
thing and you know I loved rugby and
love contact sports and all the
associated stuff with it and until I got
to 44 I'd never read a book and so then
read Rich Dad Poor Dad I thought
spellbound to be honest with you and
read it over and over
why do you spellbound my grandfather
made money back in the 80s and he passed
away before he could really pass things
I believe to make he was a cockney came
down to Cornwall but an entrepreneur as
well he went to Africa to start up that
tobacco farm didn't work out came back
did a milk round became a farmer for a
point and then bought a small holding
and a builder came to him and said I've
muddy money but you've got some land I'm
just more holding if you let me build a
house on that land I will sell the house
and then I'll give me the money back for
the land which I believe is something
like a lease about time whether or not
it was a lease option or whether or not
that was signed but the grandfather was
doing property to deal with waiting
creative joint ventures and stuff
absolutely when I was 10 and you know at
that time I wasn't able to pick anything
up from him the Rich Dad Poor Dad the
spellbinding bit for me was actually
yeah there's another there's another
world my grandfather left me a few quid
when he passed away and I bought a
cottage in Cornwall for about 27,000 and
all of my family are employees through
and through which is a big thing because
I was very influenced by the people
around me I love them to bits
imma listen to people well I bought this
place for twenty seven thousand at that
time it rented out at 375 now I coulda
buy to let mortgage which I think was
about six or seven percent at the time
it was higher than what you have in the
bank and I thought I was doing something
criminal because I know the mortgage was
this much money and then the Rena that
was coming in was this much more and I
thought I'd to keep it quiet because
Jennifer us I'm doing something illegal
here why isn't everybody doing this yes
I went on a remortgage that one aboard
another one and we did some bomb
conversions in Cornwall but they were
all single let's and done in a very
amateur way to be honest with you didn't
know about refinancing I did have any
files but it didn't know there the
theory behind it I just wanted to get
some money out of it which ended up at
his bad debt because spent it on
holidays and and other things but the
Brits Dad Poor Dad thing was yeah he
look at bad debt and good day I knew the
basics behind it but it didn't have that
I think first time I met you you know
you said to me about
work is strategy I have confidence in
what you're doing
I lack that confidence and joining the
Academy and over take my hat off to you
Julian the Academy has given me that
confidence I think you've had push
ampere and the winners on a Wednesday
yep he's part of our group you know he's
he's fantastic part of your mastermind
within the Academy yeah absolutely and
him and his brother sat here in this
very table so he quite and they've
become really good friends and they've
got an essay business and but but also
it's the way the way that he does it and
for me you know I read a book called the
go giver and it's a business concept if
you like about and I think I've heard
you say this before if you help as many
people in life get what they want
mm-hmm you'll end up getting what you
want absolutely yeah well I didn't
understand that for a while and it was
one of those because I think the
opposite is to go getter and you know I
thought in life very much old school if
you want to be successful you've just
got to plow into things and you've got
to go blindly into things and it's all
about work ethic and I think I was
brought up that way and you know there's
a lot of it's good to have a work ethic
but to do it blindly is absolutely
ridiculous yeah you need a strategy
which is what I was really searching for
it's about the original question Rich
Dad Poor Dad Wow that gave me almost
like I can imagine my grandfather saying
those things he may never had not set
those things but it was something awful
yeah Wow
that's the basics that's what bad that's
what good death is you know I've seen
you can reduce that you can look at your
pots in law so what year was this when
you read that book and then what
happened that was about three so three
or four years ago yes and that was when
you then start up a network marketing
business yeah I don't even etwork
marketing business because of a friend
yeah I trusted him seemed like a good
idea
save me if you quit so I went along with
it what you said was very interesting
though about how it actually it's not
really network marketing business it is
but really it's a person or development
program with a compensation plan right
so so you get introduced to all these
people like Jim Rohn and all these books
and CDs and you're growing as a person
which
would never do in a job and it makes you
think entrepreneurial a well in use in
education and I mean no disrespect to
the management teams that I work with
general because there was some amazing
people in there but it is an institution
and you know the bell rings you teach
the bell rings you stop teaching and you
go on CPD which might teach you about
assessment or marking or the national
curriculum but it's not about you as a
person and I love the opportunity that
you've given me at a since or close
because I've changed so much in the last
three or four years it's it's ridiculous
and I think some people close to me will
say you brainwashed you do you know what
you know because it's and I know is
because they care about me but it's a
misunderstanding I think why do you
think people in your family would think
that you're brainwashed and don't you
think results speak for themselves
like if you're you know you're doing
property deals you're successful you
don't need to work anymore a job because
you've got a property business and
you've got your network marketing
business what do you people say that you
know for a long time I've been the
risk-taker if you like in the family and
you know coming from a background of
employees about three generations in the
police force
yeah i'm celina for the police force and
just try to go and tell my grandmother
sorry I'm sorry grandma I'm not gonna be
a police policeman and she said what
you're gonna be and I said a teacher and
that was the next best thing if you like
which gives you an idea of kind of the
mentality of you what would she have
said if you'd have said I'm gonna be a
property investor well what she wouldn't
have understood it - I don't know she
would probably keeled over I should
think yeah just because that was sure
she was a strict Methodist she played
the organ in the local chapel and you
know that was that was her understanding
of a tick in the box if you like yes
right I've been a risk-taking I was
lucky when the grandfather left me a few
thousand pounds when he passed away but
I knew that wasn't right just to sit
there and and create bad debt from that
janilla yeah like spending money I think
I'm naturally a saver if I'm honest for
you I know you've had people on here
which are certainly spenders but it's
about having
balance and having those pots of money
so actually you can work and you can
spend within your meal and when you say
pots of money you're talking about at
the crash course where I teach how to
manage your money how the difference
between good good debt and bad debt how
to invest smart and all that kind of
stuff
how's that how's that helped you then in
life well it's so simple it is so simple
and now I've got a wallet with about
seven different cards in it because
there's different bank accounts set up
for a savings account for a play account
yeah I'm actually I'm not very good at
that
do you know of spending money on
yourself and I'm doing a parachute jump
for charity on a Friday which is a
comfort zone thing and I know I'm
shooting around at the moment but that
was another big thing about comfort
zones I think I was on a course a little
while back and you knew that I was
sheltering in my comfort zone and you
know you're 27 on 47 or 20 years you've
seen you but you know what you came over
and dropping me that day because you got
me off on stage and said right if it's
all about HMOs and I knew after speaking
to Alastair which I'd really like to
talk about is mentoring as well because
he's been a red great inspiration to me
yeah but I remember him talking on stage
at the first time and he'd said Sammy
brought me up on stage and he said I
fell flat on her face and you laugh but
then picked him up and constructively
rebuilt him and the next time he was a
thousand times better and I've just seen
him talk in front of a hundred and
twenty people today and it was
inspirational yeah it was a complete and
utter difference in such a short time no
I'm used to talking in front of kids up
to a thousand kids on an assembly I'm a
partner is the same she's still in
teaching and you're not one of your
crash courses I spoke in front of a
thousand people that was sat there at
the end which was my legs were shaking
Jenna and what's the difference what is
it it's you know children to adults
adults that are gonna start judging you
maybe I don't know yeah the fact that
you get out of your comfort zone and
you've got me on stage that okay and I I
went up quite willingly because I know
I've got to do it but for a long time
I've sat there and I look back in corn
or a big fish in a small pond waving and
I never really pushed myself
and yeah financially do you know I was a
really slow burner for us you know I
chased shiny objects for a long time I
sat in this room with you when we had
our strategy we were going to go for
deal saw sinks we don't have a lot of
capital at the moment and we're going to
try and create some passive income by
cherry-picking the best deals and if the
lease option comes along fantastic clear
plan absolutely and then all of a sudden
here but why not sa cause good at si I'm
chasing that I'm chasing somebody else
I'm chasing and it took a long time to
actually say whoa hang on a minute
cuz actually you know I left some
property in Cornwall now three or four
that we kept from the development time
which has kept us going with a passive
income but then other people came to me
and said well hang on you're lettin
these places how much you charging and I
was undercutting local agents they came
to me and friends and found number ended
up with 15 or 16 properties but it's a
job and yeah once I really understood
the passive and the active and I had a
lot of acting I still do so I'm not
financially free but on a full-time
property
yeah aim is very clear it kind of goes
like the first goal is to be full-time
in property next goal financially free
then ultimately financially free and
then it gets to the point where it's
just mission absolutely and I guess
there's crisscross between them but I
mean how does it fail meant to be
full-time in property successfully how
does life compare now to when you were
insane teaching oh it's absolutely
totally different you know as much as I
jumped around a little bit I said about
the charity jump it's you know the Y was
really important in network marketing
you always have to have a why what are
you actually sat here for him do you
know I have three kids that aren't kids
anymore got twin girls who were 20
they're in Australia now and I've got
allowed you 16 Ellie 17 and they're
gonna want to go in University and I
want to provide but I don't want to
provide money and say look there's a
load of money
go for it I want to provide a financial
literacy
yes being paramount for me what I've
picked up now I've done three crash
courses so I've really used and abused
you hospitality and thank you you're
welcome anytime and I came to the first
I was blown away and I actually came
with my bookkeeper who sadly has been
diagnosed with a terminal illness and he
was another reason that I made the jump
if you like he was another reason not to
shorts but he came along and said look I
know you want to do this I'll support
you we go up we get the two tickets we
go and I went and learned so much that
day that I came back to speak to a
partner who will admit she's
institutionalized he's been a teacher
for a long time a Sippel I found
something here and I don't really need I
don't want you to agree with me but I
want you to come another look for this
and I tried my best not to Marla he's
going to say this to the medic he's
gonna say that in a minute in this and
she suffered there for two days cuz the
crash course value for money is is
phenomenal I think the first day you do
nine and Sue about half-past 9:00 10:00
at night
yeah and from a teaching point of view I
know if you teach for eight hours
you're you're slaughtered at the end of
the day you're doing it for 12 hours and
I'm not here to blow smoke up your
backside but when I came in and saw you
on stage you had I think it was about
eight or nine hundred people in that
crash course the first one and you have
them right there and you had them there
for two days and I left teaching
thinking wow I push that behind but I
don't think it was the education I was
leaving behind it was the system that it
was within and to see you work with
people that really want to learn from
you there's a few there skeptics there
are still a few skeptics and you could
hear the awed whisper around I think
what you're doing here do you know and
there's almost people that are doubters
that they want to prove things wrong
maybe to make himself feel better
but to see you work with those people
there two days it did inspire me as you
know as an educator if you know as much
as my why is to create a financial
literacy for my kids I'd like to take
that further in the long tiny to prove
myself and I don't think it's lucky
breaks I'll put a lot of work in and
slowly things are starting to turn
around now yeah lunda allister's
mentorship and working with Max as well
as fantastic there is an element to me
even though my big chart and it's almost
the extra little bit
supports its that Lilith yeah all right
you're doing that buying on this
situations come up what do you think
when I'd say that in that situation and
she not after joining the Academy and
going through that Wow
at the moment we've got our money in the
bank to looking at a chunk of money
which proportionally at that time was a
large chunk of money and then to look
about four months later or four and a
half months later and think wow that's
the best money that I've spent and
really look up value hmm cutting around
but I you you said about the the book
the 4-hour working week and about
working out what your value is and what
your what your worth is your hourly
worth and actually if you've if you're
doing something you're working for
yourself and you're early worth is fifty
pounds an hour why would you wash your
own car or why would you pay somebody I
sorry what would you spend time doing
stuff when you can pay somebody to do
anything and that just made total sense
but it's it's another concept to get
your head round the thing is people
might call you brainwashed now but
actually I think most people are
institutionalized are actually in the
brainwashed ones people that think that
after work nine to five for 40 years to
then retire with it with it with a
pension in their sixties or seventies
that really looking forward to the
weekends that's brainwashed the fact
that that's normal and the fact that
people think that that's okay when you
can very easily live a life of freedom
where you don't have to worry about
finances you don't have to constantly
look at the price tag of everything you
can live life on your terms I mean
really that's that's not being
brainwashed that's just living a good
life surely so it's fantastic and I
totally get what you said about you know
you being an educator a teacher I'm an
educator and it's it's it's it's it's a
mission and you've even got a whiff of
that mission
it starts with I want my family I want
my kids on the same I don't want to
leave my kids millions of pounds up what
I want to leave them is I want to leave
them with a millionaire mind and not
just my kids but actually all my youtube
subscribers and all the crash course
delegates and it becomes a mission and I
think it's it's part of changing really
what we're doing is we're changing
nations we
changing the way people think we're
changing the way people see themselves
see money and given people a much better
quality of life so I'm really glad that
you're in on that mission and in on that
vision and being part of the Academy and
I do say I'm in a fortunate position
that I'm full-time into property which
has allowed me the time to come and
spend but I've gone on your courses over
and over I've gone on thousand Kings
which was amazing and I don't have a
strong faith but I'm very open yeah and
to meet the people from that network was
amazing absolutely amazing and a very
very different feel
yeah thing I've ever done before Oh back
to the money bit from what you're doing
in Uganda yes you know you found
something that you really want to give
to and you'll continue into gifting
that's one thing digging wells and
providing fresh water but also you've
run some business enterprise yes which
is I forget the analogy about the fish
yeah all I say is I say there's a saying
which most people have heard which says
if you give a man a fish he'll eat for a
day but if you teach a man a fish he'll
eat for a lifetime and I believe in both
so what we do in Africa is we don't just
give people fish but we don't just teach
them to fish we do both so we give water
we give food and practical needs because
if you try and teach someone to fish
who's starving it's not it's not it's
not nice so we give them practical
things but then we also run business
workshops which are free and we also
give out free business loans for
entrepreneurs and budding business
people to go to start businesses because
I think the really true entrepreneurship
is what changes as nations and I believe
in being a generous capitalist whereby
don't don't expect the state to look
after the people but let the people look
after the people and you know we don't
venture to Uganda and Zambia in places
and just give we want to build up
successful entrepreneurs from within the
villages to then give themselves so it's
just good news all round and that's what
we call the projects that we do well
that analogy is exactly where I want to
go we need to start with my family my
children my nucleus but I don't want you
to stop there yeah and as I learned
and I've no doubt I'm not going to start
do you know the knowledge that I've got
now I need to implement and create my
own financial freedom
hmm and then pass that on yes and you've
done that or doing that I mean most
people that are successful financially
they hide away and the reason that you
know normally when I was when I was when
I was growing up and I was doing
property you know as a teenager I'd meet
if I met someone that was doing really
successful and talk about a little bit
success but absolutely killing it in
property you know owned a lot of
property development whatever usually
trying to pick their brain was like
trying to get blood out of a stone that
keep their cards really close to their
chest they wouldn't tell you what
they're doing and then they'd be quite
secretive about it and I kind of want to
be the opposite of that I don't want to
hide away as a successful person I want
to vlog what I'm doing on YouTube you
know show people reveal exactly what I'm
doing to give other people hope and also
to give other people the education tell
me about the property deal all that
you've just done where you've made a
seventy thousand pound finder's fee
before I did the big thing for me is
JD's name's Jeanette joint ventures yet
to get ventures and I'm fascinated by
business and I was in a partnership when
we developed with a builder but the
whole principle the whole basis of a JV
is so simple and listening to there's ed
DfE when we came down listening to that
and Trevor actually is fantastic yeah
and the basics of putting up head terms
to get there and just having it
conversation and actually put it on
email and actually get into a place
where okay how are we going to make
decisions on this you know what's the
exit for for this and how are we going
to communicate just the basics of it I
love talking to people it's all about
relationships which when you said the
Hathor up thank bingo I found something
you know that I can get out and talk to
people and that's been the thing once I
actually started and got out of my
comfort zone I started speaking to
people travelling around the country and
it that's the biggest thing for me is is
finding people that not necessarily have
the same expertise or the same skill set
that I have but
bring something together hmm and this
the deals that we've done have all been
through joint ventures which have been
phenomenal for us because we found we
found deals and in Northeast linking
share generates a truck to an HMO
manager who turns out to be a
sophisticated investor he's been through
an education package over the last eight
or ten years he's developed and property
through Lease Option agreements and is
developing quite quite a varied
portfolio now and Janette hwisun went
off HMO rooms to all sorts of which sat
there for three hours talking about
property and business and and it was it
was this likeness straightaway and there
was a connection and Gina because I
wasn't pushing well I wasn't selling
anything and it was serving before you
sell like I guess and we've ended up
doing a joint venture together and lots
of he as he's moving on to bigger deals
we're working as a sourcing arrangement
with him and a joint venture which is
really exciting who knows what's going
to happen yeah but he's got a big
Network that's tapping into in that area
and I was really disillusioned because I
had the personal development for me has
been fantastic and I we've spoken about
network marketing go for now and yeah
and I'm reading an amazing book because
Paul can't hurt me at the moment which
is about an American Marine who had an
atrocious life lifetimes growing up and
just the callous in his mind he talks
about it about how to get through and
actually most people work on about 40%
of any potential that they have and
actually reading books like that has
helped me pick me up at the end of the
day knowing that tomorrow's another day
next person you speak to who knows you
might speak to the next five nothing
nothing nothing I think you do on stage
one of these where you go across the
stage and it's exactly right and I was
stuck there at the end of a long day
lots of viewings and I think now I've
got no deals here there's nothing and I
was in an Airbnb and the guy phoned up
there was an issue of Italian I think
so what you up here for with the
business so what do you do
property investor oh I've got a property
that I'm interested in selling okay well
would you like to meet up yeah okay so
we went for breakfast the next day and
very high-end Witherspoon's
in the area and we sat and chatted and
it wasn't about property for the first
little bit
he was sauna I knew whose gaging me
Jenova what are you what what's your
background and and one property became
three and then we left and I gave him a
call back the next week and he said well
actually I've got five properties and
then after some further communication
ended up with 17 properties and at that
point I'll be honest some yard was out
of my depth you know this was one of the
first deals you know I'd stayed in this
guy's air B&B and I wasn't sure how to
handle it how to package it it was a
couple of months back that we'd started
to talk about this and the negotiations
took a little time and when he settled
on a price you know I thought wow the
figures really work on that he was you
classic motivated seller really
why was he selling he built up the
property over a lifetime he'd got
remarried and he was looking to spend
more time in Spain and he didn't want
the hassles that come along with and he
was an old school managing all
properties himself which is a lot of
property and he still has more property
so at that point I was thinking wow this
this is a deal how do i package it
mm-hmm and which was the point then that
I reached out to other people within the
Academy that had because I didn't have a
list at that time I knew I hadn't
started Alice's men to you and I knew
that was where I want to go but I didn't
have it at the moment and you can't
suddenly just materialize a list out of
fear so I spoke to another Academy
member who has done a lot of networking
his ridiculously young you know I say
about UV in 27 and me 47 and then
there's people out there at 21 and just
off the subject Leah Miller
yeah she's 21 22 now I think she might
be 20 want anyone well my daughter's at
nearly 21 and Jen I'd said to Zara look
I've just met this girl on a crash
course she's part of the crew she's
running around I think she's only 40,000
pounds a month or a figure that came up
and that you could just hear silence on
the end of the phone and she was my
daughter was in Brisbane I said let when
you're back I'd really like to take you
along to this and I saw earlier
afterwards and she said yeah don't worry
I'll catch up with your daughter on
Instagram or whatever she was contacting
social media Zara contacts me the next
day I guess what Atlee a minute just
contacted me on she came to a crash
course
sorry came over when she came back and
who knows I'm just very aware I don't
want to push because I think if you push
too hard people push back the other way
yeah but for her making a decision she
wanted twins Zoey is very academic she's
she's got a mathematical mind she knows
that she needs University I mean I think
fantastic
I'll support that brilliant and I said
even though I know what I'm doing and
where I want to go do you know if you
want to get a job that's and being
employee as long as you're open to where
the system works and you managing money
I've got no issues with that if you want
harm to manage the money I'd like to try
and help its are on the other hand she
hasn't found anything that really floats
her boat ganache and I think going back
to what you said to me about full time
prophecy I actually wake up in the
morning how no there's no issue I'll get
to come up and actually I'll try and run
now in the mornings and try and do the
miracle warning as well but it's about
having that why Anna's are hasn't found
that why yeah yeah so he knows that
she's got something that will structure
now over the next three or four years
her exact words were to me I want to
make money I said but what do you want
to do because it's really important not
knowing the job or what area do you want
to be in and do you want to work for
yourself great I'll support you with
that and there's ways of training Zara
she hasn't found that yet but the fact
that you're there and the fact that
they're coming to the crash course and
stuff is fantastic I loved it absolutely
loved it it was one in London and we
were staying in the
the Ibis I think yes but you so you got
this deal and that's the deal sorry and
you passed it on to a twenty-something
21 22 year-old person on the Academy
yeah and he then collected how much
money well he was very cool about it he
he's now in his client account as God's
seventy thousand pound fee in his client
fancy that there are 21 year old selling
your deal for seventy thousand pounds
the money is now in the bank and what
are you going to splitsies on that going
Hoffs yeah yeah fantastic well it is
fantastic and there's part of me we talk
about voices in your head is this
actually happen is this too good to be
true is this what everybody says is too
good to be true
yeah gonna come suddenly take this away
and the investors happy the investors
happy the deals still going through yeah
and who knows but it's possible Sally oh
yes you know I hear myself say things
sometimes but actually maybe don't
believe it and it takes time then one
day you wake up and go on you know I've
been telling everyone this and actually
know this is possible
mmm and this is really working and yeah
I get emotional I talked about the
legacies for my kids and you know
creating stuff for the future because
that means a lot to me and it's not
actually the money it's not I want to
wake up and I want to have a bigger car
than you or a Skoda so it's not I don't
it's not about having this massive house
or it's about the making money fit
really excites me I think playing
Monopoly as a kid I used to get very
excited about this and you know actually
now 48 years of age of 47 years of age
I've actually got a tool kit now I know
you say to me that the Academy isn't
home isn't a lottery ticket
you've got to implement yeah it took me
a long time to get I think in that
network marketing the seven green I need
a lot of information I was chasing
information chasing shiny objects
actually no now five months in I know
what I'm gonna get ahead bro to give
credit to to Alastair
yeah because he's one of the trainers on
the Academy when he's doing this deal do
sell him out yeah
morning and I said look Jan I'd really
like to give you a testimonial because
the support that you've given
considering how quickly your business as
snowfall if you like and the Academy's
growing at such a rate and which is
fantastic and I know Alice does now a
big part of that and his business he's
still hanging on Max's app obviously a
big part yeah but to be a mentee he
spent time when people really hasn't got
time and I'm sure he doesn't want to
answer my calls at 8 o'clock at night or
whatever he's doing and it's been great
and for me it's been absolutely critical
my journey because it's describing me
enough okay that's great I'd actually as
a business expense you know you look at
the finance you investment that you're
putting in
I'll talk to Rex about this because I do
news Rex each month because if we're
looking at mentors and systemising
businesses and looking how to develop
each each business Rex has been
absolutely fantastic and yeah you can
claim it back if you spend money on upon
a program a training program then you're
going to offset that against your profit
in the business so absolutely it's a
no-brainer what would be your final
words of advice to someone that was
looking at getting into property and was
wondering where to start
this should be really simple but I've
got two brothers and you know one
brother Joe is he doing his property as
well and he's watching my progress so
he's another one when we talk about
frogs and lox and he's one who's just
watching and he watches your podcasts
and he will run and listen to your
podcast how I mentioned I might be
coming on hearing his seriously he said
what so how's it going and you know I
ache for the people close to me to
support I have done for a long time but
actually coming out of comfort zones and
actually going back to your analogy when
you said to you doubt that you don't
want to be part of this business
yeah and the church yeah and you know I
look back and I gained strength I think
from that because I haven't got that
around me at the moment but you know I'd
like to think that back to you I spear
gotta get out and do it get to a crash
course
listen be open-minded know
sit there and think I want to prove this
wrong just sit down and just listen
Janice free it's not gonna cost you a
penny
come along educate yourself and I
believe there's people that go from a
crash course and go out and smash it and
I know I see people on your other other
winners on the Wednesday they're doing
that yeah for me I needed something more
I knew I needed more I've always been a
team player and I knew knew I needed the
Academy mmm and I was so glad with my
part you got to do this how's your
partner doing now she's good she's good
but the other part of it for me is to
give her options yeah do you know she's
taught for a very long time and don't
get me wrong I couldn't run the business
without her she's behind the scenes she
does so much yeah but to give her
options would be absolutely wonderful
that's a crime well I'm really grateful
that you've come on the show and I look
forward to seeing your continued success
congratulations on all you've done so
far
and it's been a fantastic interview
Thanks thank you so much Jeremy thank
you so much for watching the video that
is the reason why I'm doing this your
success is my oxygen every single week
we've got people becoming financially
free if you'd like to see more success
units you can do that right here but
what I'd really suggest is why don't you
come and join us at the property
investors crash course come on on my
guest completely free and I'll
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can see what happens
right here what you'll notice is all of
these stories they all start at the
crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there
peace out